sie gehört nicht nur zu den schlimmsten
soll man wohl auch zudem mysteriösesten
tragödien der polarforschung die
franklin expedition warum mussten john
franklin und die weiteren 128 menschen
bei dem versuch die nordwestpassage zu
durchqueren auf grausame art und weise
sterben erst in den jahren 2014 und 2016
konnten die beiden gesunkenen schiffe
hms terror und hms erebus in der
kanadischen arktis aufgespürt werden
jetzt gibt es die ersten wirklich
spektakulären aufnahmen aus dem bauch
des geisterschiff der hms terror kriegs
um science fiction die gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen insgesamt 129 menschen
starben wohl auf grausame art und weise
im frühjahr 845 war die expedition des
britischen polarforschers sir john
franklin gestartet um eine abkürzung
durch die kanadische arktis zu finden
die nordwestpassage vom atlantik zum
pazifik das alles geschah im namen der
britischen krone doch der versuch
scheiterte klar ist alle mitglieder der
expedition kamen uns leben doch was
genau franklin und seinem team
hoch im norden kanadas zugestoßen ist
ist immer noch ungewiss
eine handgeschriebene nachricht zu dem
schicksal des teams wurde bereits im
jahr 1859 gefunden sie deutet darauf hin
dass franklin und rund 20 weitere
mitglieder bereits im juni 847 gestorben
sind
zu den todesumständen selbst enthält
dieses schriftstück allerdings keine
informationen im frühjahr des darauf
folgenden jahres im april 1848 ist das
schiff höchstwahrscheinlich im packeis
stecken geblieben und die 105 übrig
gebliebenen besatzungsmitglieder hatten
versucht das eis zu fuß zu verlassen
doch was dann die kälte der hunger oder
gar eine bleivergiftung der seeleute die
ihnen den tod brachte einige relikte der
mitglieder konnten aufgespürt werden
genauso wie einige gräber und klar ist
das wohl der kampf ums überleben wo
lange und grausam gewesen sein muss
manche geschichten erzählen von
kannibalismus etwas mehr weiß man
mittlerweile immerhin zu den beiden
untergegangenen expeditionsschiffe ms
terror und hms erebus die erst vor
wenigen jahren aufgespürt werden konnten
jetzt hat die kanadische
nationalparkverwaltung neue spektakuläre
aufnahmen veröffentlicht die
taucherinnen und taucher im bauch des
gesunkenen geisterschiff heimes terror
gemacht haben behilflich waren dabei ein
kleiner ferngesteuerter tauchroboter der
wirklich einzigartige aufnahmen machen
konnte das wrack selbst wurde vor drei
jahren 2016 in einer tiefe von 24 metern
in einer bucht von king william island
gefunden mittlerweile wird sie als
terror bay bezeichnet die untersuchungen
des unterwasser archäologie teams
dauerten sieben tage lang und haben sich
auf jeden fall gelohnt das unter deck
des schiffes ist gut erhalten und 90
prozent dieses teils konnten von den
fachleuten untersucht werden der anker
wurde nicht ausgeworfen und das wrack
liegt aufrecht am meeresboden das alles
konnten die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler jetzt erstmalig sehen
und ihre schlussfolgerungen dazu sind
deutlich demnach sei das schiff wohl er
plötzlich und unerwartet gesunken und
sehr sehr schnell verlassen worden es
sieht also alles nach einem drama aus
dass sich vor etwa 170 jahren abgespielt
hat die bilder der aufnahmen spreche
nicht für sich zu sehen sind tische
betten regale mit flaschen messgeräte
andere instrumente und porzellan dazu
der projektleiter ryan harris was uns am
meisten überraschte war der unglaublich
gute erhaltungszustand die kabine des
captains francisco see allerdings konnte
das taucht im zum großen bedauern der
fachleute nicht erreichen doch genau
hier werden nicht nur aufzeichnungen
sondern möglicherweise auch das logbuch
vermutet dazu ryan harris schriftstücke
könnten aufschluss darüber geben was
passiert ist die chronologie der
ereignisse
wann sich die beiden schiffe trennten
und wie sie dahin kommen wo sie
schließlich verlassen gefunden worden
diese hoffnung besteht da das kalte
polare wasser und der geringe
sauerstoffgehalt möglicherweise dazu
geführt haben dass das papier gut
erhalten geblieben ist schon im
kommenden sommer sollen die untersuchung
weiter gehen und die mysteriösen
todesumstände und das schicksal der
terra möglicherweise gelöst werden die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sind optimistisch dazu rein harris diese
aufnahmen bestätigen dass die
möglichkeit hier schriftliche dokumente
der expedition zu finden nicht nur real
ist sondern dass es sogar wahrscheinlich
ist dass wir eine bedeutende zahl
solcher dokumente finden werden das
wrack der hmsc
könnte damit entscheidend dazu beitragen
endlich das rätsel um das fatale ende
der franklin expedition zu klären das
ganze video gibt es hier bei parks
canada guided tour in zeitz ms terror
anklicken also hier anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran